We do get a piece of advice from a friend...
...when we told them that we're gonna open Soul Cycle.
And he said, you know, "I don't have the heart to tell you this,..."
"...but you know spinning is dead.
So, indoor cycling business is probably not a good idea.
And we were like, "Well, I think we could still do it."
"I think we could still reinvent it."
"I think we can still create something that we want as the user."
So people looked at us and said, "You're gonna charge what per class?"
"And somebody could get that included in their gym membership for as much as they wanted?"
But we really decided that pay per class model was a challenge to ourselves.
We thought that if we charge each time people came that we will be challenging ourselves...
...to create an incredible experience each and every time.
And so we went for it and it worked out really well for us.
There will always be naysayers around,...
....and the truth is that when you put into act together with your gut,...
...you're gonna get there.
I think the lesson when people give you advice is that you need to trust your own instincts.
You know your business best.